ciao a tutte loro io vi prego di non
chiedervi perché del mio outfit
io ho si le maniche corte in casa è il
cappello di lana
ma il vero motivo per cui sto facendo
tutto questo è che o ai capelli vi di
gesù di nazaret è per questo che ho
deciso di indossare un meglio un
biglietto se 10 servendo us army e un
berretto di lana sia vero non
nascondermi capelli sia per cagliari lo
scalpo sia anche per omaggiare l'inverno
che tra parentesi sta pure finendo io ho
un tempo adoravo da neve
perché non l'avevo mai vista io
veramente iniziato odiarla con tutto il
cuore anche perché poi risvegliati
ricordi veramente brutti ogni anno ti
vuoi spiegare sul tema andando sciare
sbrigati nuovo guardano comandate
sanzioni meno visto spiegami che cos'è
un ultimo a mettere la calzamaglia volli
mi calza a rete magari di santi piatto
aggio era una bambina poi successo gusti
c'e un sacco di giapponese il si mettono
sotto italia delle mogli e tranquilla o
tre bellissime al sabato a verde cosa
dimmi tu trans o peter pan
io lo so che poi la sensibilità di peli
circonciso il modello non era sua e non
mi sembrano troppi dove che quanto il
mio moroso domani sul metodo di natale
caricare e può essere premiati sono
anche misura stesse persone
inoltre facendo da soli quindi non ho
imparato a sciare l'onta e software
portato della carta o siti ingresso il
pacco che poi ripensarci avevo dei
motivi molto più validi verso il termine
adeguato al resto del mondo già comunque
il mio cappello può sembrare una cosa
banale mia verità ha fatto pochino
ragionare su quanto sia facile ma
vedersi cioè potersi far del male a
vicenda con poco spesso e volentieri
chi non è il tatto non anche gli altri
sensi tiburon al gusto perché chi vomita
merda solamente di una cosa con note
riservato infine o magari non vede o
almeno vede però quello che vede lo
filtra collusione vede solamente quello
che volete vere o ma o ma guarda c'è la
[ __ ] a palena rilascio però non si
scherza su queste cose che possiamo un
problema alla fine ma guardate che noi
da chi vuole posso mica [ __ ] come
quell'altro bene vai alla cintura le
saponette così magari tempo torna utile
che si sa mai
ciao
ma
che cazzo staff a questa pianta ma
progetti
ma sinistra e pm comunisti a destra che
tuttavia non e fascisti monti magari
luogo da ma tanto se metto ricetta
cambia niente tanto succede non avranno
che tutto nasca da dei cassonetti ma c'e
la raccolta differenziata pesca ed
elettorali grillo ma che cazzo è
pinocchio tutto fritto tutto finto è
finto è finto segreto è finto che lo
vendi finto tutto finto c'è ma mai finto
che schifo adv su quattro ne basta
vedere o magari una costante licenza del
resto degli studi non dicono tipo che
noi usiamo il 10 per cento il nostro
cervello è come avere i 10 euro e
potremo usare uno solo e magari lo
spendi pure male magari troverte in un
tombino invece di rubare i carrelli il
supermercato che è farceli discese mio
non vuole essere un discorso buonista
cioè io voglio solo un anche se
effettivamente con questo video
velatamente contro il bullismo spero di
potermi comprare un posto nel regno dei
cieli
però guardate il tipo di tipo io a volte
veramente vorrei fare un applauso alla
sensibilità e delicatezza con la quale
gli autori trattano gli ospiti ci fanno
fare fanno di salti pindarici da un
argomento all'altro in maniera
totalmente assurdo
gli spettatori per tutti voi che non
avete nulla da fare
la sera comunque queste casa con la
nostra intervista cosa i cordini di
quella sera nella quale sia stata
stuprata da una mandria di tori non lo
so non ricordo niente io canto sapienza
che continuano così vano emotiva non è
successa la stessa cosa con uno sturbo
di confine giusto cosa ricordi o no non
lo so non ricordo diretto ricordo che
milano non bubi la impugni la vanoni con
nervi bollivano che non vivono non
vivano gradivano para vivano è anche
l'anno in cui hanno già nessuno che lo
sa
questa terribile di sana pianta della
figlia bensì la propria ma adesso
passiamo alla storia di margarina banche
come ben sa anche di qualcuno e quindi
niente non so come finire questo video
sono in difficoltà quindi potrei usare
la tecnica del tagliamento che magari
non conoscete ma che vi mostro subito
molto volentieri che questa
comunque a parte tutto quanto si
stendeva
possiamo fare un ringraziamento a tutte
quante le persone che hanno continuato a
seguirmi nonostante i miei due mesi di
assenza
prometto che tornerò a fare video tra
parentesi è finito il video se non
interessa più questi qui sono tutte
chiacchiere su progetti futuri quindi
potete anche chiudere fatto un perfetto
e quindi mi scuso perché sono stato
molto impegnato con il coronamento di un
altro sogno che è un romanzo che sto
finendo e sono felicissimo però adesso
sicuro sto finendo finalmente posso
tornare online e fare un sacco di video
vi terrò aggiornati più avanti non
voglia maron harvey scocco libro adesso
bracci no no no no è fondato su un
famoso quartetto quell'opera qualcosa
il corpo di tribuna ma sempre e tripoli
non dimenticherò mai